okay this is what I wrote the document
object model stores data about the
content of a page and the properties of
each node to build the dom the browser
parses HTML and creates tokens from HTML
tags some tokens indicated tags start
others indicate a tag end the tokens are
converted into node objects forming a
tree structure which we call the Dom the
relationships between objects in the Dom
tells us which ones are parents and
which ones are children it's also worth
noting that Dom construction is
incremental which means that we can
start building the Dom as soon as we
have the HTML and we don't need to wait
for the entire HTML page to start
building it